okay well I did not get the job in New
York but I got the real prize domestic
bliss John made me breakfast this
morning
well she bought the milk it's soy this
is why I do it that's what I have to
come home to she probably won't be up
for a few hours this is going to be a
very good year very good
Jane is at home Jim is back my protege
Ryan is a corporate good stuff
Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed what about this
one
it's kind of bad I was right just seems
kind of crazy in a way I might need
right now I don't know oh that's not
yours Stanley just drank OJ out of my
mug and didn't seem to realize that it
wasn't his hot coffee so the question
has to be asked is there no limit to
what he won't notice what's a
seven-letter word from purse actual No
starts with an H handbag hmm thank you
all right everybody take a seat as you
may have heard our branch on the planet
Jupiter is up eight thousand percent in
sales
[Applause]
look pluck a slope it is five o'clock I
will see you all tomorrow I Stanley love
you so long Stanley all right everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
you follow the home
[Music]
this is how you make it in this country
[Music]
[Music]
you get free jump and find them it's so
hard to love you sometimes still by
[Music]
crazy haha
[Music]
[Applause]
Toby how do we do well that was better
[Applause]
coat Michael just rented The Devil Wears
Prada
he has his Netflix sent here to the
office and he watches them in pieces
when things are slow steak where's my
steak he's a big Meryl Streep fan so I
shouldn't be surprised that he's
identified with her character didn't me
Armani a suit on the fall and like the
main company number cuz I'm gonna have
to call him who's Armani
he's on the phone too slow you're not
going to Paris I'm so much better than
you
I owe you an apology you finished the
movie yeah where's awesome big surprise
ending will ruin it for you
no go ahead Meryl Streep is the bad guy
you never see it coming
anyway if I was mean in any way to you
I'm sorry I just want what's best for
you a manouschka macushla he's watching
Million Dollar Baby he's gonna try to
kill me yeah that's no problem yeah sure
uh-huh I know you are you can fax it
over
yeah five seven zero five nine nine one
seven live lang
zero one seven five thank you okay it
really makes us look unprofessional they
would never know it was me doing it here
we go
knock knock who's there Buda Buda Hill
Buddha this bread for everyone I need
something to wipe my head now there's
there's better that was nothing it was a
classic I got a knock-knock joke no okay
God Michael please please please please
please let me all right
not now who's that KGB changing the hell
was that what are you doing what are you
doing hey stop it stop it hey come on
what are you doing man as part of a
hilarious hyo's retribution what are you
doing
no more knock-knock jokes that's it
dingdong who's there give me try get the
door I'm not answering answer dingdong
no way Jackie Chan thing though I'm not
answering that yes you answer the KGB
will fit for knowing it's true
hey Michael yeah contractions are coming
every 10 minutes okay just remember to
keep breathing my cervix is ripening
okay good
Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm
donor and Michael is preparing for the
birth of a watermelon with the white now
this baby will be related to Michael
through delusion Michael yeah my waters
breaking okay okay what do you do I get
a call from Jan and I meet her at the
hospital right highways or surface roads
I take Quincy AB to Gibson no Gibson is
covered in potholes your car breaks down
adapt I check the route there are no
Polamalu the circumstance it would you
like to have my baby yes babies are one
of my many areas of expertise growing up
I perform my own circumcision just keep
pushing oh babe right here pushing free
mummy up I want anesthesia no you can't
have it it's too late no I don't want to
just push it out okay keep stimulated
yes okay wouldn't the baby emerges
market secretly in a kind of a mark that
only you can recognize and no baby
snatcher could ever copy ready yes Oh
God
Wow what was on that butter newborns are
slippery nice touch good let's try that
again I just going to big the happiest
day of my life
you